I want I want you to tell tell the story
about when you were an acid or no no not
acid when you were dating that American
Indian girl Ramona yes and what did you
do what do you mean Steve okay you were
in Phoenix right you were seeing an
American Indian girl Nam Ramona yeah you
went to her house at 3:4 in the morning
when you were drunk didn't I already
tell you guys I don't know about no
Native American okay so was this is when
I was uh drinking a
lot so like your eyes I was uh you know
I was at the bar and you know drinking
some
beers and uh it might have been a week
night I don't know but I was there with
some skater dudes I don't know how good
of friends whatever yeah
um bar
closes um and I'm like and this is uh
Ramona had moved into uh out out of the
dorm she had her own apartment she was
living off campus yeah and I knew she
was off University so I'm like dude she
like lives right there yeah so this is
you know around two I go there
unannounced I remember she lived on the
second floor so I just you know I
knocked sound effects no answer no
answer okay I do it
[Music]
again no answer yeah but then this turns
into my skateboard truck
uhhuh oh you do it with your skateboard
truck with my skateboard truck okay
murderer I know the I know I know I was
drunk I was so wasted this is in my mind
oh booty call on out just craziness
right I didn't know this at the
time but Ramona had she was living with
her pregnant sister oh my God and the
pregnant sister's husband which I didn't
know he's probably in UFC right now he
knew some [__]
so I'm thinking oh Ramona's going to
answer the door but it was some big
Japanese dude I've never seen yeah
before you know it he had he Shucks me
down and has me in a [__] body lock
yeah and I'm like this and then what did
you say I go this doesn't concern you
man I was like this I was like this this
doesn't concern you
man
I was like I want to talk to Ramona yeah
yeah and I ended up going to
jail jail he went to jail I went to
jail I don't know but dude I the thing
is this is what why I knew this this
dude had skills cuz I wrestled for like
seven years dude and I was like trying
to peel and risk control and the guy was
such good like he had me in a kamur I
don't know reverse kamora loog or
something so I was like this I was like
he had my wrist control so I'm like in
my mind I'm like dude did po wrestling
what the [__] my PO wrestling it's not
working working and so um we you know
were doing that on the ground and then
before you know it there's two or three
cops in the apartment did Ramona ever
come out no oh you never saw Ramona
again huh nope was it the right house
nope okay she didn't even leave her room
words and I say I'm going to just say it
think it through I'm through through you
got me laid oh that's right I remember
that story now I don't know yeah that's
a good one yeah you right I don't know
you you don't go tell what is he do I
dude dude tell I don't be mean though I
don't mean be mean to but really really
laid out backr no don't be mean you do
it okay so you tell the story this is
when Bob was performing at the 10 p.m
Prof okay yeah but I was I was attending
yeah but I was not headlining I was was
opening for I don't remember caros oh he
was opening for
Carlos so I go you know I'm like cool
I'm in the my dorm is literally right
down the street from where he was
performing yeah right down the street I
lived at the little dorm you know I was
seeing a girl God who's the girl I
seeing Oh Jean yeah Jean yeah Jean was
like like a paler white kind of you know
yeah yeah and then Jean I don't even
know her friend's name but she was like
a fat Latina woman like pretty fat not
fat pretty fat really fat pretty fat
yeah yeah yeah
umle really bad and um and then my
friend Brian from Chicago remember my
friend Brian we'd rap together and stuff
so we went to see him and then I go set
up like maybe an Afterparty in my dorm
room or something oh no tell we wanted
to take you to lunch yeah so my brother
that day so my brother's like yeah man
we're going to go to a restaurant one of
my favorite restaurants in the whole
world like he classed it up as if we
were going to Morton's right and and
he's steakouse yeah he goes my tree you
know what I mean like we're going to
this classy classy place my [__] you
know what I mean you're going to love it
dude La style right and he takes me to
Mongolian Barbecue no no Mongolian
walk where you go line put Frozen beef
in a bowl right they weigh it but dude I
was a Col student I didn't know you know
what I mean like I didn't know good
places I thought that wasn't Gourmet
though it wasn't was highend to you it
was highend to me cuz I ate wy's every
day yeah um so thank you for that meal
okay and then okay I don't kind of a
this no I'll just tell you exactly what
I ended up doing okay well I painted a
little bit we're in the same room at
night we're in the same room we're in
Jean's dorm room we're in the girl's
dorm room he's with this girl white girl
Jean and I'm with the other one okay
okay
and yeah yeah yeah and um no condom no
no no no you did I did wear condom cuz
you walked up to me I was with Gan and
you go hey dude do you have a there's
condoms
here he goes hey dude sorry is there
condoms yeah yeah so I I get up I go
yeah yeah and I go to the the desk and
she had them in the desk oh she did yeah
and I gave you one and I wore it yeah
thank God thank God you don't remember
that I don't remember I do but here's
what here's what I do remember oh go
okay and this is where I'm probably
going to go to hell he was in and out of
there so fast not only that a year later
well hold up you didn't even complete
the story I don't want to get into the
sexuality of it why not because I don't
if she's listening I don't want her
feelings you yeah I mean it's it's not
right and it's probably inaccurate it's
so long ago yeah it's a long time ago
but here's where I was the biggest
[__] a year later I'm opening for
Paulie MH at that same room yeah and I'm
on stage and I see front row in the
front row and she's looking at me with
these sweet eyes right and when you
where you walk off the stage right is
where I you literally walk by her so I
Crush I go good night right and she I
get off stage she grabs my arm and I go
like this get off me Bobby
Bobby she grabbed me like that I go get
off me like that and I went to The Green
Room and I waited until everyone left
the club after poie was done and then I
went out why why was that Instinct you
don't touch me just embarrassed
I I just
crushed get off me you me yeah it's like
you know what I mean oh my God [__]
[__] I feel bad about that now is it
partly my fault that you're back in no
it's not your fault st's a [__] grown
man it's not no but but in what but it
doesn't help when you call me at 2 in
the morning
cly do you think Bob can play
we're doing Trials of Osiris and I
really want this new gun so yeah yeah
wow great impress oh my God even during
the UFC fight you see the whole fights
were're going on he Taps me on the back
he goes yeah there's a bunch of people
in my house we're watching pay-per-view
UFC and he Taps this little tap on the
back I'm like yeah
go hey so tonight we're doing a
firefly fire team our fire team needs
yeah yeah can po yeah and then you could
see cuz she knows now that I'm the one
that told you to tell her no but she has
a good she always has a good response
she's like dude he's a grown ass man he
could do whatever he wants but that see
that's not what do you mean when you say
something like that what there's a lot
behind that you think that's a loaded
response for me no it's no I'm just
interpreting that there are a loaded
response you probably just mean that the
way it is yeah well oh I'm sorry you
know I think you're very well aware of
the consequences of your action I don't
have to reiterate those to you every
time so it's like yeah that's why I you
know that certain things make me unhappy
yeah so I just what to said yeah fine
now if you played and he was actually
kind of a pleasant person to be around
when he played destiny different story
I'm trying to be better though but you
know we have a puppy so it's like even
if the puppy's in front of he'll have
the puppy [__] and piss and do
everything he'll neglect completely the
world he he'll not feed the cats he'll
not feed himself the dog I've been eat
all day today yeah what not one thing
this is the these sunflower seeds is the
first thing I'm eating you I think
there's another thing that kind of adds
to that which is kind of getting under
my skin is uh
cheaters I was not expecting that what
do you mean Who's Cheating what do you
mean well I'm learning mhm on Destiny
yeah oh there are people that cheat
there's I'm I'm learning have you heard
of lag switch in man what is that okay
so basically uh lag switching is when
they [__] with their internet connection
like where they go from green bar to Red
Bar so we'll be trying to kill someone
doing um Crucible they'll beat you and
the guy the opponent will vanish or
it'll be like a delayed movement where
you're shooting at like a shadow but
then he his [__] is normal he could kill
you so it's a delayed thing so lag
switching and there's a thing that they
also do dosing which is they uh they
kick you from your connection yeah but
then so there's cheaters how does that
even make it fun for you guys if you
know you can never win if people if
cheaters are winning CR we can win a
regular Crucible game we can win and I
don't mind lag switchers because
sometimes we've won with them but dosing
they'll kick you from he did that once
to him and he was Furious boot it off oh
is that when I needed to give you the
credit card over and over again no no
that wasn't the um
that was no no no that was that was
that's another thing I want talk to you
about that's another thing I want to
talk to you about okay yeah is the your
tone when it comes to that [__] cable
bill we squash this no no I'm not I
don't give a [__] look at me right now
okay I'm going to say this and I hope it
doesn't embarrassing at you yeah I'm
paying for your cable I know he's paying
for my cable bill but you got me into
Destiny you're like dude I didn't have
it I was on AT&T I was doing my own
thing and then once rebutt I'm just
saying I'm letting you know I was paying
my own [__] AT&T I only had the and then
you were like you need to get a better
connection I need you in Destiny me okay
all right Bobby you brought him in no in
the meim who said so like now Stu yeah
so I'm sorry I mean I get this stuff
yeah so I mean I didn't want it I had my
own little shitty internet and you up my
[__] so I mean that's so I had to kind
of speak that but you're right but the
thing is I have a whole weird thing with
bills anyway I freak out if I get
something and they add interest or I'm
weird with taxes I'm happy when you text
me that I mean if you don't want me to
like take a picture of the thing and
send it to you guys I won't do that
anymore no send it to me don't send it
to him cuz he's not paying it I have to
be the one to pay it so I apologize I
mean I I'll go down now that I heard you
out I'll downgrade to a lesser thing no
Steve it's fine just don't send him the
text send it to me I'm the one who pays
it anyway I heard you out I apologize I
should but I I I was fine with my shitty
connection I know but oh so you want to
go back to your shitty connection no cuz
I
love I love the it like oh I don't need
the [__] thing you know no I like
Destiny I like I swear to God I didn't
want to talk about this
but okay okay so I was shooting this
movie okay well before I went okay I had
a 7 o' p.m. call time Saturday night so
I drove to Sherman Elks or no Woodland
Hills that's where it is okay and I'm
driving to the I see a
Gamestop I go I'm going to get a new
controller right now and head seat piece
so I went in there bought they gave me a
gigantic bag I put it in the car then
the you know I parked where the parking
lot is they drive me to the set I
[__] worked 12 [__] hours it was
brutal was it a movie yeah it was a
movie oh and at like 5: in the morning
we did second lunch which is like they
have to do it sag Union wise mhm and
then they go we got this this
meat I go where is it from we don't know
some place I'm like 5: in the morning
where do you get meat like it was like
chicken skewers uhhuh chicken or beef
chicken and beef but I ate the chicken
but 500 a.m. yeah chicken in the morning
maybe it was Halo guys it wasn't Halo
okay it was not not it wasn't good it
was undercooked man it was under I don't
know what happened but diarrhea and then
at like 6:00 in the morning I I'm on my
last shot like 6:30 and I just start
farting a lot oh you know what I mean
and then even in the scenes yeah in the
scenes and the cameraman goes even one
time goes what's that smell and I didn't
say anything I didn't say anything cuz
in my head I'm like if I if I can just
pure [__] just get in my car drive home
I just have a 2hour session in my pocket
right P poo so then I wrap I don't fill
up my paperwork which I still have to do
sometimes sag paperwork and I get I have
the van drive me into my car
I'm in the car it's now Sunday morning
I'm on the 101 speeding and then all of
a sudden in my head I go I'm not going
to make
it I'm not going to make it to a
restaurant yeah I'm not going to make it
home not at home even anywhere oh the
[__] was building up no it was out it
was probably out it was wet yeah like my
underwear was already Brown a little bit
it was peeking it was peing yeah so I
pull over and I go to a gas station I
par park into this gas station it's
closed the gas station right I go to the
back seat I pull my pants down and I
throw the two boxes you know what I mean
that's in [__] GameStop bag sh in
your car yeah and I [__] in the GameStop
bag you [__] in a bag yeah yeah in a
GameStop bag you [__] yeah yeah and I'm
not even kiding you it was filled with
juice was it Sol juice I mean was it
solid or juicy it was all juice it was
pure diarrhea juice I threw bag I'm
still the gas station that sees the
GameStop bag I'm sorry if you hear this
but I threw it right C pull my pants
back up and now my underwear is cold
[__] cold poo oh that's the worst so I
sit on my seat and and it's cold poo
just pure just [__] everywhere yeah yeah
it's not it's pure it's all poop okay
pure it's pure he had to wash his don't
come home right and I um I take my
underwear off no no this is what
happened after that I I go to a
Walgreens so I'm walking in in Walgreens
with this the W right through the thing
I get wet naps right and I get um I buy
two or three extra bags Jesus and so
then I take the underwear off I put it
in this these two extra bags I threw it
in the trash can I wiped my [__] out
as best I could I stick the pants back
in but there's still poo of my jeans I
come home and then quinda comes out and
she sees me putting the [__] jeans in
the [__]
sure it was just a bad bad morning that
was considerate a you to poo in a bag
though yeah have you ever done that that
was a first no I [__] on a house with
her she he [__] on someone's plants did
on some like gardinas yeah yeah yeah but
it like it wasn't even intentionally
into the gardinas it just sprayed back
yeah yeah as he was bending over it just
sprayed backwards with just that
propulsion you know it runs in the
family though wait what the the Dad yeah
well my dad used to um remember he had
the store in Riverside he had a van yeah
he would take shits in like paper on
paper plates
yeah you don't remember that oh yeah on
a paper whyer PL he didn't even want to
go to he was he had to get there so he
would just pull to the side and go in
the back yeah but that's not a you think
that that's a behavioral like a Le thing
I don't know D have you done something
like this it's in our jeans or to do
that to maybe poo in public maybe you
guys find a thrill out of it no I had to
go like my my dad I went to a store in
Phoenix we had a clothing store yeah and
underneath the couch register you don't
even know what I saw no I don't even
know the story I saw a gigantic jug of I
thought it was water oh piss it's all
pee he pissed in a [__] J no he cuz
he couldn't afford any
employees so he would so he couldn't he
had to go to the bathroom take break he
would pee right there they in The Jug oh
my God that's hardcore that's commitment
that's good work ethic you used to do
that too yes remember he had a truck no
he had a this is back when he had the
white truck the Toyota get close to the
okay so Bob had a white truck in San
Diego Toyota yeah and he would have
Frappuccino
bottles come on dude this is real [__]
and it was filled with Frappuccino
bottles it with urine in the Frappuccino
no bottles just stacked there's no even
caps on those that's dangerous no no he
put the cap back Capp ones right so you
just collect your a urine collector you
just like
collecting dude what would you use it
for oh I [__] up I [__] up I
just I don't remember
that so so it doesn't exist I don't
remember it it doesn't exist I don't
remember it you lying no I remember see
he's a PE collector he is he really is I
did it on the bcon here you did I used
to pee in the the gigantic green thing
for years for years I I've done it too
what is wrong tell me m Gatorade bottles
but why same yeah same but you collect
them on purpose no no this is the thing
sometimes cuz I don't want to walk all
the way to the when I'm in about to go
to sleep and I'm like I'm dozing off and
I I don't want to walk get up and walk
there Steve how big is your place how
many steps would you say it takes to
walk to your bathroom swear to God for
step for probably from
here to the bathroom out there so
proximately eight steps eight steps so
you'd rather pee I just stand up pee in
the Gatorade bottle close it and then
lay back
down so that's how lazy you are that's
pretty lazy yeah that's pretty lazy I'm
the same way I I don't know what it is
the same way you are I'd rather do that
than walk than walk but he doesn't you
probably you're very clean it's deeper
than that though it's like the Sleep um
Interruption like when you're about to
go there it disrupts it more when you
take you want to have the same thing
with sleep what do you mean what do you
mean you don't want to be woken up oh no
and if you get woken up Suddenly there's
a rage you don't want you didn't want to
wake my dad up too growing up in that
house o story what
happened um when he beat me with the
keyboard yeah oh yeah that's okay so I
heard that story so me and my
friend uh David
Oliver D Oliver was uh we were in my
room and he had one of the first
sampling keyboards uh Casio yeah and it
was the one where you press the button
go hey It Go hey hey hey you and it go
it would go lower and so I'm like this
is the coolest thing I'm like do the
Freddy Krueger and then we mess around
with it I guess it was too loud and it
was during the day my dad was taking a
nap so he [__] B he just bursts
through the front door butt naked and he
goes yeah yeah and then he and he pulls
the keyboard out of the socket like
unplugs it and just starts beating me
naked on my back now imagine this he was
like boom boom I'm like a white there's
a white there's a white kid laying
beside like on his stomach
just and then and that's not he never
he's never seen [__] like that so he's
beating me like I'm like
no you know I was crying and then the
beating ended and then I'm like go to
the bike and then I [__] and I and then
I look he's walking he's naked and he's
walking to the door and I see something
sticking out of his [__] it was a uh
like white it looked like a uh you know
the string of a tampon yeah yeah yeah it
was white tissue paper mhm like a string
sticking out of his ass yeah this is
what you call the Korean kite Korean
kite Korean kite and what and why does
he do that and because I asked over the
years I think it's to kill the moisture
yeah to kill but yeah to to make it his
butt more dry yeah yeah so let me ask
you a question is it appropriate when
your Dad's sick and you're in their
house to look at your brother and go Bob
can we go to Walmart to get
Pringles you son of a let me ask you
something is it
appropriate um and then yes and no okay
so why why did you want me to get
Pringles well I we're so bored and no no
no you okay I was bored Bor you know
girl girlfriend's not around yeah um I
was sick of
masturbating with just uh
Vaseline cuz I was just masturbating
with uh Vaseline and I would you know
paper towel yeah yeah okay and so I
looked up on um YouTube or Google um you
well I looked this up I said I looked up
homemade uh Pocket
[__] oh you did arts and craft during
your definitely definitely arts and
definit arts and craft so what I found
out is you could take simple household
supplies and make
a kind of like a fifi like a just a
pocket tell me how from beginning to end
it works good surprisingly how does it
become a vacuum though I'll show you
want me we'll break it down I won't show
you but break it down okay break it down
for us well let me just say this before
anything okay what happened that night
well I'll tell you what happened okay
you go Bob yeah check this out which you
think you're going to see like you know
a cool soccer footage of something or
you know what I mean or a fail you know
you don't think you're going to see an
instructional manual on how to to make a
[__] homemade pocket [__] H they do
so we saw so we saw it mhm and then what
did we see um so what you need is uh two
sponges what kind soft or the scrub part
uh the soft ones yeah cleaning right
yeah the cleaning sponges they sell four
packs at
Walmart um rubber bands o and then
simple just like plastic uh like grocery
store uh you know like the bags to stuff
it in the Pringles
reg plastic yeah just regular PL plastic
bags you forgot the most important part
oh latex gloves there we go when that's
the vagina that's the vagina that's your
vagina you line it so what happens is um
well we were at Walmart and I we bought
two Pringles and what what stop stop all
right
okay this is something that I would
never do on my own okay yeah was like a
brother it's something that that's not a
brother thing [__] that's not bonding
even [__] bonding ing all right was
that [__] bonding it was fun dude it
was fun it was fun it it it was fun
because it was fun because of telling
you what you getp the cloves go get the
cloves where do you get Glo you mean
that he would even walk around Walmart
with me I had to do it separate she's
like dude just yeah yeah you go get
everything I'm going to go I'll meet you
here I'll meet you over here so he has
two um Pringle you know the the what do
you call them cups cans
right flavor uh I think I got sour the
onion and then just the normal there was
like a new yeah yeah the brown Sal I got
salt and vinegar oh God yeah yeah
whatever I think maybe mimic me yeah
yeah salt vagina I feel and also
um we it went to waste because we didn't
even eat the no we we actually walked
outside of Walmart looked around and
then and then I just I just dumped them
you guys couldn't wait till you got home
no no he was afraid his main fear was
like my mom discovering well here okay
so here's
so so what you do is this okay did I say
rubber bands you did rubber
bands what you do is you take the two
sponges okay and you take the glove okay
hold on okay so you sandwich the two
stumps of sponges on the glove no no no
you the the two sponges are like this
yeah and then the glove goes in the
middle you sandwich it you sandwi that's
what I [__] said so what's touching
your penis has to be the glove right yes
yes yeah because it's and the inside of
the of the sponges the sponges are like
so the glove opening right you you wrap
it right so you sandwich it but then you
wrap it around the um the two sponges so
it holds in place and then outside um
outside the Pringles the top of it and
then you just rubber band it so it stays
in place okay so it kind of like it just
uh does that kind of motion yeah yeah
yeah and then um you have two SP we
little arts and craft session upstairs
did you try it or did you try it mine
felt great did you got one too you made
one too two there two vinegar his broke
mine's broke mine broke because I big
dick Bobby no it's not that I did it too
aggressively yeah yeah yeah I mean and
he got mad cuz mine I got the pink
sponges and he mine looked more like a
real yeah and I got a green
one Avatar like Avatar Pandora you're
trying to mimic my [__] you gave me
fungus so yeah it would
be and so what what what I found through
oh we we we forgot the lotion we bought
well forget the lotion [__] the lotion
okay what I found is that you have to
kind of rubber band the top the like the
top entrance part really tight because
mine busted open I don't understand how
the rubber band Works what do you mean
okay if you're lining it you're lining
the inside of the can with a sponge and
then the inside of that is the glove
right where does the rubber band
actually go well this is Bob discovered
this he modified also Bobby you're the
one that's been doing all the research
no the next night the next night he goes
dude I got it he's like Steve you learn
you learn to grow and that's what life
is about Lear and he's like cuz we had
to re uh redo it yeah so he modified it
so before we even put it in the Pringles
can he uh rubber band it all
together the sponges um the sponges with
the latex glove so it sticks stay
together so it's a tighter vagina cuz if
you don't put the rubber band around
there then imagine it's like your dick
will open it up and it just becomes like
that's it you know poor [__] oh poor
you say poor [__] Poor Poor [__] yeah
yeah but like so I I put it you know I
put tightened it you tightened it tried
it a second time just to see babe don't
get angry this is amazing just to see
yeah it's pretty cool my theory work I
kind of want you guys to make it like I
know we should actually should have
brought it dud the thing is is this we
made it the first night and I hid mine
during the day my brother just leaves it
out I go what if mom walks up there no I
hit it like on the side of the bed and
oh you did yeah I thought like you left
it out no way no oh yeah yeah no so you
guys each have your little canned
[__] and then who tries it first you
or him we didn't do in the room same
room I
mean brother let's do it together at
what point did you guys convene and then
say hey like did it work for you the
next morning or the next day next day to
comp we said good morning yeah know you
say you you don't talk about it right
when you wake up you have coffee morning
later like a couple hours later
awkwardly I turn to him I go did you do
it mhm he goes yeah it works so good Bob
mhm I got mind busted open so you know
well this is my trick is I don't know if
you tricks tricks well was like my um my
style was um I didn't use um I didn't
use lotion Vaseline so I took Vaseline
you didn't tell me about that I didn't
no see that worked that's why yeah but
you should tell me that that's did did
you go dry baby no we brought
Jurgens know how I yeah we bought like I
bought five or six different kinds so my
question is is this a onetime used
pocket [__] or do you nut inside and
how do you clean it oh you just take the
latex glove out and then discard it oh
so you can reapply it was a 50 glove
package we bought yeah we bought a 50
pack oh
[__] made 50 if we wanted to yeah yeah
if we wanted to yeah but anyway um we
did that while my dad was downstairs
Dying God Jesus guys you know so it's a
weird way to put it though yeah but
that's the thing I hear that sadness
does cause people to be hypersexual
though yeah you think
so you made a homemade pocket B with
Pringles I know I mean there has to be a
name for the both of you yeah like
actually you know what Pringles should
give us money yeah well we didn't eat it
that's the problem they eat the we eat
the
can't ate your dick it wasn't the other
way we ate the we used the vessel it
comes in you know so I feel like they
could make money off of it anyway maybe
shout out to Pringles oh yeah they could
no they
can't see they can't all right I mean
work it that way yeah no they can't
they're not going to have two Korean
guys on their [__] C Pringles the new
face of Pringles there a big billboard
of you guys with like Pringles on your
Des you know how like um Anthony Kus
with the socks on
and just piles of Pringles on back of us
cuz we don't eat them we don't I had a
dream about you the other night and I
was thinking about that dream don't look
at me right now you being serious no I'm
serious what was the
dream we you made you weren't there you
were in the dream but you sent me and
Bob you lived in San Diego in a house
that's where you lived in a house in San
Diego yeah okay and um and then the
whole reason why you live there is
because you're like I don't like I like
the commute from San Diego to la la I
wrote some of it down I wrote you wrot
you wrote it down yeah I wrote it down
oh please tell my brother wrote down a
dream cuz right when I woke up can I
read it maybe if I can read it let me
just see if I could read his handwriting
let me just read let me I won't read it
online let me that's a gross Rel let me
see let me
see oh it is true Gil look it it says
right here on the top Gilbert dream
please read it can I read it yeah well
it won't make any sense it doesn't
matter I think that's I think you can
inter let me read the whole thing and it
okay my brother wrote down on a piece of
Pap Gilbert dream in parentheses not
parenthesis uh parentheses those aren't
parentheses what do you call those
parentheses parenthesis okay bracket
yeah San Diego house Mir Mesa question
mark
[Music]
papaa pasta
sausage chop long
jalapenos B then you said one bedroom no
bedroom San Diego house oh yeah and this
says my left room you guys
order more can Mo back and
forth our mom skip in dog
[__] yeah get on your carpet resolve
spray resolve spray yeah only the Bob
went down halila said us went to gas
station to set you blunts Phillies eight
pack right it said
zigzags but two
expensive no slide
Sho what it's a Escape trick oh no nose
Li shove it nose Li shove it oh yeah
infant recognize AA blank dude wow
that's like very poetic so okay no
that's your next song yeah um Gilbert
dream so what happened was go close to
the mic okay so what happened was you
live down there and so we are in your
living room and and
uh I like went outside and you guys had
ordered food without me like I was went
Papa John's no you had it delivered and
what this but it was from Papa John's it
no papa Ho's what's Papa ho is just the
name of this Italian restaurant you made
up your own no it was a real place in my
dream is a real place no so you made
wait wait wait no in your dream it was
papaa that you ordered papaa I ordered
papaa yeah that's your favorite Papa
doesn't exist it doesn't exist so in
your mind you created papaa Papa in
my so Papa Hows You Got and I went into
the back into the house and you're
eating this delicious delicious pasta
delicious uh pasta uh platter and it had
um those long sausages you would get in
pasta but then meatballs too so
meatballs long sausage and jalapeno
uhhuh and I remember in the dream like
wo you guys didn't order me any and then
you guys were eating it like like really
enjoying that so what's other stuff I
left and then somehow okay commute back
and forth and then my mom entered the
dream I don't know when that happened
but she stepped in dog [__] and uh tried
to go on your carpet and got it on you
used resolve spray yeah cuz I think that
stem we used that here and my mom has it
at
[Music]
home it's so good I'm glad I read it
first now everything's cleared up this
is like kind of yeah resolve spray to
get the [__] out of the carpet cuz
that's resolve sprays in my mom and
dad's in Gilbert um only B talk the mic
talk to the mic okay okay and then
somehow we ended up the gas station cuz
you wanted to uh you had weed mhm and
then I got you uh you're like uh you
wanted blunt and I got a Phillies eight
pack Blunts and that's when I did the
skate there's red curbs and I did a
skate trick and then oh nose you did no
and then these guys in AA walked up and
I go hey what are you guys doing here
you're in San Diego too and then that
was a
dream how did it make you feel why did
it and you wrote it down I wrote it down
cuz there's it was DET the reason why I
wrote it down because there's details in
the dream you know what I'm saying's
your interpretation of it I don't know
what do you think it means the last time
I saw you was like two months AG I know
but you were in it it was your house it
was your house and maybe because you had
just come back from Gilbert Arizona oh
Gilbert
Gilbert there is a correlation with my
name and the city yes wow Gilbert
Gilbert Gilbert Gil holy sh holy [__]
I'm sorry for it just it just stuck with
me I'm like I got to tell I don't know
what when did you write that down last
night two or three nights ago you wrote
it down two or three nights ago well
right when I woke up I I'm like you know
I should write cuz I remembered the name
of the Italian Italian restaurant papa
papa
we got open one guys yeah we got to open
one doesn't that sound good it's a pasta
dish listen listen pasta dish marinara
sauce meatballs and sausage jalapenos
long jalapenos on there have that in
every F to except the jalapeno does that
exist George that was weird the jalapeno
what he's not Italian for I don't know
why yeah why' you look at him like he's
F Italian you would know yeah I don't
know well that was really interesting
that you would write down your dreams
why did you always write down your
dreams the first time no there's a
couple I have a couple like a notebook I
have a couple dreams I WR here's here's
what I details I like the details do is
to come and and read some of your dream
book to us yeah start a dream book he
has one yeah details huh did now let me
ask you did it when he read the stuff
did it sound like a crazy person wrote
it no it just sounded like you were
jotting down notes of what you to
trigger the memory yeah why did you keep
that I don't know CU I I knew I would
see you and I'm like you know what this
be interesting to bring up going to go
that's cool dude no I don't know what it
meant I don't know why I don't know why
maybe we should analyze it yeah oh can
we get a maybe a dream interpret now how
do we do that we already figured it out
Gilbert Arizona it might not be that too
it might be how you feel about Gilbert
yeah I have a house in San Diego Gilt
you don't want him near you he's so not
the type to smoke blunts either doesn't
smoke BL know I know maybe it's his
future no it's not his future I book a
show then I moved to San no you get out
of the business Get Out The Bu you get
so depressed you start smoking blunts
San Diego though yeah but you're such a
foodie so you open a restaurant called
Papa but then I like to commute to La
for no reason he just do the podcast
though oh
I it's the only thing you can hang on to
podcast oh [__] something bad's about to
happen to you this year [__] I'm so
depressed but think of papaa maybe
you'll have your own Italian chain of
restaurants or like a good Papa that
sounds like good like a good name please
shut the [__] okay okay